[Applaus]
sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
morgen feiern wir den dreißigsten
jahrestag des mauerfalls dieser november
1989 ist für viele ein tag der freude
des gedenkens des nachdenkens und der
besinnung zu zufällig und irrtümlich wie
er zustande kam zu folgerichtig war es
dass der selbstbefreiung frank der
ostdeutschen zum fall der mauer führte
die ddr war eine geschlossene
gesellschaft
das reisen in viele länder blieb den
meisten menschen verwehrt
es gab erhebliche einschränkungen in der
freiheit der demokratie bei der
versorgung mit waren und
dienstleistungen
es gab auch staatliches unrecht die
mauer und die tödliche praxis der
grenzsicherung waren sie ein gröbster
ausdruck ja auch nicht dadurch zu
rechtfertigen war
dass die mauer die trennlinie der
systeme markierte und von den
großmächten im kalten krieg als gegeben
akzeptiert wurde
alle toten dort sind nicht hinnehmbar
reisefreiheit
weil deshalb neben der meinungsfreiheit
der ablehnung von zensur und
bevormundung eine zentrale forderung der
demonstrantinnen und demonstranten von
plauen über berlin und leipzig bis zum
vierten november in berlin
man muss noch einmal in die augen der
menschen sehen die am abend des 9
november vor 30 jahren frei und
ungehindert aus ostberlin in den
westteil der stadt strömten
man muss sich ihre glückliche
fassungslosigkeit über die friedliche
überwindung der mauer vor augen rufen um
die historische dimension
der leistungen viele ostdeutsche vor 30
jahren zu erkennen
diese leistungen müssen ebenso wie die
leistungen der ostdeutschen in den
jahrzehnten zuvor und in den jahrzehnten
danach endlich angemessen gewürdigt
werden
es ist das erste zeitgleich gewinn in
gleicher arbeitszeit und gleiche rente
für die gleiche lebensleistung in ost
und west zu zahlen
außerdem muss es endlich gemäß artikel
36 des grundgesetzes so viele
ostdeutsche in führungspositionen der
bundesbehörden geben wie es ihrem anteil
an der bevölkerung entspricht
der bevölkerungsanteil der
bevölkerungsanteil bei 16 prozent der
bei den führungskräften nur bei 1,7
prozent
der grundstein für die ereignisse vor 30
jahren die später dann auch zur
deutschen einheit führten wurde mit
denen von gorbatschow eingeleiteten
entwicklung von perestroika und glasnost
gelegt es ist aber auch ein die rolle
von solidarnosc in polen an die flucht
in bundesdeutsche botschaften und an die
grenzöffnung in ungarn zu denken
deshalb muss die erzählung früher
einsetzen als beim fall der mauer auch
weil sich mit diesem historischen tag
der fokus der akteure freiwillig oder
unfreiwillig mehr und mehr in richtung
der deutschen einheit verlagerte
zuvor ging es um eine veränderung der
ddr wie gesagt es gab in hier
staatliches unrecht trotzdem lehne ich
den begriff des unrechtsstaates ddr
weil weil der frühere
generalstaatsanwalt von hessen fritz
bauer diesen begriff zu recht für die
nazi-diktatur prägte die
bürgerrechtlerinnen und bürgerrechtler
wir demonstrieren wollten zumindest bis
zum fall der mauer die ddr grundsätzlich
reformieren was möglich erschienen in
einem unrechtsstaat wie nazi deutschland
war dies ausgeschlossen
er konnte und musste abgeschafft werde
wegen der reichspogromnacht
wir denken wir morgen auch der durch die
nazis ermordeten juden und juden aber
den mauerfall und auch die deutsche
einheit hätte es ohne die gründung etwa
des neuen forums von demokratie jetzt
und dem demokratischen aufbruch ohne die
demonstrationen und leipzig ihren anfang
und den menschen die angst nahm und
schließlich bei der demonstration am
vierten november 1989 in berlin die
einen höhepunkt fanden nicht gegeben
ich muss es ganz klar sagen wir
demonstrieren
in vielen städten haben erfolgreich für
freiheit und demokratie in der kirche in
der ddr gekämpft und ihr mauer zu fall
gebracht
nicht helmut guth und seine
bundesregierung brachten das zustande
es war die leistung der osten die
bereitschaft der menschen vor 30 jahren
bis dahin unerhört ist einfach zu tun
mit massendemonstrationen neuen parteien
und organisationen das machtsystem der
sed in frage zu stellen ohne es
gewaltsam beseitigen zu wollen folgte
einem uhr demokratischen impuls der auch
den heutigen verhältnissen durchaus um
täter die runden tische zum beispiel
waren ein demokratisches instrument das
wir uns aktiv erinnern sollten bei der
lösung aktueller probleme die
friedlichkeit hat er zwei seiten keine
gewalt durch demonstrantinnen und
demonstranten und der verzicht darauf
bei den soldaten bei der polizei nicht
gleich aber später auch egon krenz hatte
wohl am abend des 8 oktober angeordnet
keine gewalt mehr durch die polizei
anzuwenden
es bleibt eine beachtliche leistung das
während des gesamten umbruchs kein
einziger schuss fiel
weder durch sowjetische greift in der
ddr noch durch die angehörigen der
sogenannten bewaffneten organe der ddr
auf und gerade nicht am abend des
mauerfalls als an der grenze keiner so
richtig bescheid wusste und sich
diensthabende entschieden die grenze zu
öffnen
beides ist zu würdigen nicht schwarz
weiß sondern das große sagt zwischen
bestimmt den lauf der geschichte
die iaaf nicht kommen
die afg plakatiert wende 2.0 und will
angeblich die wände vollenden
meine wenigen damen und vielen herren
von der afg hier mit der wende mit dem
umbruch mit der friedlichen revolution
hatten und haben sie nicht das geringste
zu tun
die mehrheit der ostdeutschen die
mehrheit
stolz wenn sie zu die mehrheit der
ostdeutschen wollte die mauer zum
einsturz bringen nicht wie sie die
errichtung neuer mauern
die mehrheit wollte ein vereinigtes
europa entschieden dass sie zerstören
wollen die demonstrierenden wollten
freizügigkeit und toleranz und nicht wie
sie das nationale egoismus rassismus und
antisemitismus verbreiten abschottung
und ausgrenzung sind das gegenteil von
dem wofür die menschen vor 30 jahren
demonstrierten
gerade weil heute an den grenzen europas
wieder menschen sterben die nach
freiheit demokratie einem leben in
sicherheit und mit einer
wirtschaftlichen perspektive streben
sollten wir uns daran erinnern dass man
mit mauern und nationalen egoismus
regelmäßig probleme nur verschärft und
nicht löst außerdem sind sie von der art
die feige
denn sie bekämpfen die schwächsten in
der gesellschaft die flüchtlinge da lobe
ich mir die linken die den mumm haben
sich mit den stärksten anzulegen
ich weiß ich weiß
ich weiß was sie spätere einheit
menschen in ostdeutschland zusätzlich
gebracht haben
zb die sanierung von städten und
wohnungen aber kenne auch die fehler die
begangen worden
die einheit hatte unter anderem genutzt
werden können sowie es gorbatschow
vorschlug um weder osteuropa noch
westeuropa zu bleiben
man hätte neutral und zu den
wesentlichsten vermittler weltweit bei
konflikten werden können egal ob es um
den konflikt israel palästina russland
ukraine oder andere geht eine solche
rolle kann man übrigens auch heute trotz
der nato mitgliedschaft anstreben
sie scheint mir den wünschen der
demonstrierenden vom herbst 1989 und dem
grundcharakter des mauerfalls zu
entsprechen
diese rolle wäre also vielen auch mir
schon aus historischen gründen wenn ich
an die nazi diktatur und den zweiten
weltkrieg denke sehr sinnvoll erschien
stattdessen hat sich die mehrheit im
bundestag entschieden nicht nur in der
nato zu bleiben sondern die soldatinnen
und soldaten der bundeswehr mit allen
konsequenzen weltweit zu entsenden
außerdem wäre es vernünftig gewesen
bestimmte momente aus der ddr für die
höhere gleichstellung der geschlechter
die polikliniken die berufsausbildung
mit abitur für das vereinigte
deutschland zu übernehmen
statt die strukturen
im osten völlig zu negieren und zum teil
sogar herabzuwürdigen das hätte das
selbstbewusstsein der ostdeutschen
gestärkt und den westdeutschen
ermöglicht dank des ostens eine
steigerung ihrer lebensqualität zu
erfahren
präsident auf andere schwächen und
stärken der einheit werde ich wegen der
begrenzung der redezeit erst im nächsten
jahr eingehen übrigens am 9 november
1918 begann mit der ausrufung der
republik die demokratie geschichte in
deutschland auch daran sollten wir
denken und der fall der mauer aber
sollte uns alle mal probleme wirklich zu
lesen und nicht zu versuchen sie mit
bauern durch einigung vorübergehend
unsichtbar zu machen
77 prozent aller deutschen fühlen sich
mehr west als osteuropa verbunden so
viel zur neutralität theorie von gregor
gysi und